A new energy. A new audience. New stories.
Keep watching to find out the candid
thoughts the Witcher showrunner and executive
producer had about the show’s big name exit.
Fans of the expansive fantasy franchise
"The Witcher" are still reeling over the
news that Henry Cavill is departing the role
of protagonist Geralt of Rivia in the Netflix
series based upon it. After Cavill's final
outing in the part of Geralt in the show's
upcoming third season, the character will
be played by Liam Hemsworth in Season 4,
a casting choice that has fans divided (to say
the least). An online Change.org petition to
restore Cavill to the role has almost 275,000
signatures as of this video, and many viewers
of the show are understandably skeptical of
recasting a show's main character mid-story.
But no online petition is more powerful
than the Man of Steel, and Cavill is most
likely exiting "The Witcher" due to his newly
reinvigorated commitment to playing Superman in
the DC Universe – though some fans believe it's
because of his displeasure with the direction
of "The Witcher". Thus, fans won't be seeing
him again in the role of Geralt any time soon.
"F--k"
You can reasonably assume that
the "Witcher" showrunner Lauren
Schmidt Hissrich also wishes Geralt
didn't have to be recast. Still,
in a recent interview with Decider, she
spoke optimistically and enthusiastically
about the change and what it means
for the future of the series.
Hissrich isn't worried about a disruption
of the show's creative momentum. Instead,
she says she sees it as a positive. She said,
"You know, I will say that change is also energy.
Change also brings [a] different energy. So,
to us, that's just part of continuing
to roll forward into this franchise."
More open-minded fans of "The Witcher" might
understand what she means and will look forward
to seeing exactly what kind of new energy this
admittedly huge change will bring to the show
(and even most of the more close-minded
ones will probably still check it out ).
Recasting Geralt of Rivia wasn't the only subject
addressed during Lauren Schmidt Hissrich's Decider
interview. With not just the upcoming third and
fourth seasons of "The Witcher" and "The Witcher:
Blood Origin" on the way but also various
animated projects like "The Witcher:
Nightmare of the Wolf," and even a family-friendly
animated series coming in the near future,
the "Witcher" franchise is growing incredibly
fast, and Hissrich also spoke on how she
sees the series fitting into the fantasy
genre that so many fans love. She said,
"One of the things that we believe
strongly ... is that fantasy is
actually for everyone. There have
been points in time, in history,
that it's a very narrow audience. I think
all of [those] different access points,
if you will, all that does is make people fall in
love with the genre more, which is what we want."
She's also not worried about
the franchise hitting any kind
of critical mass regarding
audience endurance, saying:
"It's interesting because could there be
fatigue? I actually don't think so. I think
the stories are so vast and also so varied,
and I think there's so many different ways
into the world that we could keep doing this
forever and we'd never run out of stories."
"Have no fears. We've got stories for years."
Fans will get their chance to see the
next phase of Netflix's "The Witcher"
saga when the four-episode "Blood
Origin" prequel miniseries hits the
streaming platform on December 25th, 2022.
And Season 3 of "The Witcher" main series,
which will star Henry Cavill, is
set to come out sometime next year.
"This is where we part ways, Bard. For good."
"Look I promised to change the public's
tune about you, at least allow me to try."